people are starting to make some really
cool ships in style field this is the
Planet Express from Futurama made by
Reddit user sp7 all how awesome does
that look oh my God uses steaming hot
data dump made the UNSC Pelican they
actually made a guide to teach you
exactly how to build it which is like so
unbelievably awesome and I feel like
they nailed this got that Halo green
this one is probably my favorite the
Normandy it's made by someone called
bizzle94588 I feel like I gotta try and
make that that's so neat oh it's a ship
from Cowboy Bebop how cool this one was
made by veracia well and then there's
this one uh big ship that just says hi
because you could put like a ton of
boxes on the top of your ship this one
was made by casaloop um oh my gosh
it's a flying high uh how beautiful